let's get the view from labor should we
standing by for is the shadow leveling
up secretary Lisa nandi is with us hello
teamers nandy thanks for joining us on
the program this morning criticism from
the Germans saying that you know we
bullied our way in there we didn't ask
for permission we took our diplomats out
and it impacted on other nations getting
their civilians out Tosh says the uh
foreign secretary this morning uh
Germans are standing by their accusation
well I think the foreign secretary is
right to say that we had to act as
quickly as possible to get our diplomats
out and I hope that the Germans will
understand that that every country has
to do everything that it can move Heaven
and Earth to get it not just its
officials but its citizens to safety and
the key here is to learn the lessons
from the Afghanistan evacuation and to
make sure that not only are we
partnering with other countries and
moving very swiftly but we're also
coordinating across government
departments here in the UK to make sure
that the left hand knows what the right
hand is doing
would labor create legal routes for
fleeing Sudanese refugees to get into
the UK
uh look I think there's a there's a
sensible conversation to be had about
making sure that people who are fleeing
persecution have a way to reach safety
but that has to be done in conjunction
with the International Community and if
I were in James cleverley's position
right now what I would be focusing on is
firstly the evacuation and secondly
about making sure that those neighboring
countries have the support that they
need to deal with what is likely to be a
very very high influx of people fleeing
the situation in Sudan those countries
are likely to become very strained very
very quickly we've got to make sure that
the International Community works
together to put together a response that
will at some point include of course all
countries considering what we can do in
order to help ease that burden but right
now that's got to be the priority
because I suspect that the humanitarian
situation will deteriorate otherwise
very very quickly thank you
um
the Home Secretary eventually go up
there Zola bravman on the sofa yesterday
morning talking about new police numbers
and she was telling me that they are
going to get the numbers up to an extra
20 000 you'll say that it was a cut of
21 000 I know but the fact remains that
there are more police officers on the
street now than there were in 2010 we're
told well I mean where are they you walk
down any Street in Britain I think
people are really struggling with the
fact that there isn't a high police
presence on the street we haven't just
had cuts to the front line we've had
cuts to the back office as well which
has hindered the police's ability to
respond you know you know Wigan very
well okay I was in the Town Center just
a few days ago talking to business
owners who say that when they have
frequent shoplifting in their shops that
often people coming into shoplift in
order to make money to fund a drug habit
which creates a vicious cycle of of
crime
um they call out the police and the
police can't immediately respond because
they're under so much pressure which
means that those criminals get off
scot-free it's causing absolute havoc
and misery in communities across the
country we've got a properly funded plan
in order to get more police onto the
streets we've been urging the Home
Secretary to adopt it for over a year
now I don't know what's taking us so
long I don't know the problem is but
it's about time that this government did
something and if they won't labor will
they have they've increased the numbers
by 20
951 since 2019 and there are three and a
half thousand more police officers now
than in
2010 when labor lost power
well it's very difficult to see what
where those police officers are you know
but we we have been pushing we've voted
against every cut to police numbers
since 2010 because we know how much this
impacts on communities and we've been
pushing a plan to bring together the
procurement of separate police agencies
in order to ensure that we can get more
Frontline police on the streets and put
that money where you get most bang for
your book that's because crime has got
to be a priority for any government
worth its salt it's why it Formed one of
Labor's Central missions for government
it's one of the key things that we plan
to deliver on the truth is that for most
people in communities across Britain the
story of the last decade has been one of
Decay and decline where they've seen not
just criminals being allowed to walk
around and get off scot-free but even
those criminals who are caught uh there
are lengthy delays in the court process
and Justice delayed is Justice denied
for too many people we we've promised
that we will sort out that backlog in
the courts that we'll get more police on
the streets and finally this country
will have a government that takes that
seriously
um George Osborne uh when uh he was in
charge of certainly the chancellor
um his he had a help to buy scheme I'm
sure you'll remember that criticized by
experts for inflating the market instead
of helping it you're coming up with a
similar plan
we we believe it's unconscionable that
on current trajectory one in three
children born today won't be able to own
only one in three children born today
will be able to own their own home by
the age of 50. and we think that Trend
needs to reverse people deserve the
security of their own home and our
solution to that is twofold it's to
introduce a mortgage insurance scheme
along the lines of Canada and Australia
other countries that have similarly
helped people who pay very high rent
payments for long periods of time but
can't make the leap into Home Ownership
because they haven't got big deposits
and they can't pass those checks to walk
alongside them to help them to do that
but at the same time to build more
houses that was the problem that George
Osborne had because this government has
been in hocked to its own backbenchers
who don't want to see houses built in
this country for too long they managed
to create more demand for housing but
they didn't increase the supply and that
had the effect of inflating house prices
we believe that you've got to do both
together we've got a plan to do both
together and if this government won't
act to reverse the decline in home
ownership then we will
um just before I let you go um Angela
Rayner how worried should she be about
her job suggestions I'm reading that
she's going to be demoted in a reshuffle
I think Angela Rona is a phenomenal
talent and a great asset to the labor
party
um and I I can imagine right now she's
doing exactly what she's been doing for
the last few weeks which is out
campaigning in order to get rid of this
Tory government and finally give the
British people a government that it
deserves okay so she should keep a job
then and she has your full support
but it's not up to me to negotiate
between Kier and Angela about which job
title she wants to hold but I'm she's
one of our greatest Assets in the labor
party uh I enjoy working with her and
she is relentlessly focused on doing
exactly what all of us all to be doing
right now which is ensuring that the gov
the country faces has the choice of not
just an opposition to this awful
government but a genuine alternative
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thank you